hey everyone we have a very special game
today yeah well it might be one of the
best games of all time it actually is it
would probably be if you're making a
definitive list of luck games you have
to play yeah this is probably the top
ten yeah like it's actually one of those
like you need to play this and we're not
exaggerating with this like this is
right it's not hyperbole no because this
is one of those is a sports game yeah
but a transcend sports games no like no
because like if you tell someone to play
fifa tho you gotta play soccer shirt
right but this is this is a game that
transcends that like yeah thickness I
know I can't oversell this enough it was
in swingers no no was it in swingers so
what happened was in well anyway we're
talking about NHL 94 oh they didn't know
we were talking about no no one knew
you're building up to this whole thing
sanity tell me what I knew after i said
hey kid get to the title screen we got
to show him that that intro music that's
sweet sweet intro music and i actually
was an abandoned high school and I
covered the zone really now oh now but
i'll be pretty fun what was the name
your band that you weren't in a ray
bourque experience so when I was in I
was I went to like this rock museum and
they're like a little fake concert in
seattle and the name that we gave my
wife and I was like bridget tomorrow cuz
her name is Bridget and they're like
that's a great prog rock name and I was
like nah just can we combined our name
it comes to Zamboni I know it's very
slow than that very slow man out of what
gave up eight goals tonight that's a lot
of goals how do you play this game hey
hey Oh inauspicious start nothing oh god
I love this thing as you minute power
play Tampa man i can't believe that i
started it in such a mess
oh yeah you got another penalty there
you hooked me say bunch of cheaters Eric
wine wrench I'm just gonna fill up my
bench as fast as possible this is
ridiculous well that was a little bit of
Hickey it gets there NHL 94 comma still
why are you such a cheater none of the
updates are from just a couple weeks ago
boom there's a penalty yeah but it's a
delayed penalty because it was on your
oh man I was bitching dan is nothing but
sheet you've cheated thrice and I have
cheated months as an in hockey as in
life watch this watch this watch this
damn it's in your hot goalie if you're a
goalie you're weird because you're like
yeah I want it for a living I want
people to shoot vulcanized rubber at me
the same with being a catcher now
there's no ball KEH nice rubber tub look
at that if it's a teen off so that was a
pretty bad period for me do you yeah
well I'm definitely getting my my
bearings here since I play this all the
time right if you guys have any
questions in the chat about my amazing
dog Cody beside me eat cookie dough I
now he's so she's just a short little
guy why I have a question why is your
dogs are short time god I don't know how
that one in oh this might be a good time
to remind the audience that we are
moving yeah megabits moving to Monday
same time what you're gonna do this on
monday oh my god you're that shot I saw
it I was incredible so this week you got
a twofer yeah now in Monday it's like a
Oreo oh I'm not doing very well 50 50
yes out for the game woohoo oh my god I
killed him I killed him he doesn't move
I love of the only helping him he's not
even move it I love it leave him there
cnl is a week because when he when you
knock him out a quarter or a period
their legs kick his legs won't kick him
Oh what ever know either man yeah this
is this basically getting you moved this
game cuz people are just booing you at
this point right we'd rather have no
hockey then six nothing hockey yeah oh
my god Patrick that's what I'm trying to
do he's scared the crap I was trying to
get a hat chick I was trying to get a
little Hetrick wasn't you sure the
audience you dog oh my God he's the best
is the best is the best little doubt in
the world well my lead was can't find
about my goalie sucks so that or Steve
Yzerman is still good just kidding all
right but you know you got a plane in I
just got my ass kicked I'm gonna get my
ass kicked do you think it seemed better
than the Whalers I I mean I'm always I
always pick Montreal I'll be a random
team random you guys should both be all
stars what are your buttons here uh flip
pass shoot the bastard gotcha Oh No okay
listen to funct and relocated national
hockey teams the Montreal Wanderers oh
that's a good name that's a real if they
wandered outside of Montreal haha the
Hamilton Tigers Hamilton is where
brendensen clothes from former gamespot
news editor it's outside of Toronto oh
my god I'm square myself wait the Ottawa
Senators it was a two on with the Iowa
senators don't exist anymore no it W
this says 1934 their house there's a
different Ottawa yeah this is really
sure they still exist Oh financial
struggle due to the Great Depression was
the cause the same for the Pittsburgh
Pirates the Philadelphia Quakers Quaker
oh man hell that's the worst name for a
hockey team talking about not
intimidated yeah apparently we're
upsetting Marco Georgia [ __ ] yes Linda
chat yeah fo braces wow it is painful to
listen to pc brown atomic shade talk
hockey
ask ask Marco who moved to winnipeg i
thought it was the phoenixes phoenix's
oh no oh get it oh how did you know hmm
never know man is one third period and I
get this bag is time to go with the
penalty shots hence I hope it goes in a
pillow I don't think there are penalties
shots I think just over time there's
like a shootout mode oh yeah might be
something that I don't remember what
happens I never tie dye was won by 10
goals not today tom oh god oh oh oh he
is so excited look out Oh hottest oh oh
I should have been a goal that really
should have been a goal oh I want to
make your head bleed I got a tunnel here
23 seconds well oh god oh Lily injures
ding oh okay yes very good I do not
expect that well I wasn't mean it was
good Debenham Peter the button Peter you
did all right I'm gonna take one last
shot to redeem myself here well you get
to play each other now where's my deal
Oh where's the d I'll tell you were you
so neither do you've actually scored a
goal yet I know learning hockey in 35
minutes of action neither of your score
man so those are chances will be 200 who
does miss that check along the boards
that would have been fun yeah finally
what was that finally for that Raonic
gonna reserve your own except germ every
case huh oh god oh that's comical was
that own goal yeah so as eminent
stranger pointed out yes Cody is a dog
typing sometimes and so that's why you
sometimes too
shot in the chest he's got something to
say he's got something to say he's a
smart guy yes this is ridiculous Chris
Chelios ridiculous I've been playing a
lot of trials fusion and that is amazing
I know what is also so short yeah but
yeah you got the people here for
instance you have people to race pit
yeah but I because it's debate it only
gives you some courses yeah oh that's
right that's right if it's a terrible
terrible terrible Robert Goulet to score
down come on oh come on I just thought
my god no it's what one go no this is
bad bonita no this is 60 minutes getting
shutout feel terrible oh oh did i did
this all i didn't think that i took that
shot all right that does it 40 dozen
angel 94 banditos hockey career for our
careers hockey common tickets Oh Jody
got one more one more note in there good
job Cody yes you don't get to you know
yet to jump off the couch yet all right
thanks for joining us everybody remember
megabits coming back next week monday
11am no longer on fridays the whole
schedules changing inside our twitch
page can I take a look you can see it
right down there right now yeah and yeah
so stay tuned our twitter account all
announced the game I'm playing on monday
sometime later today until then thanks
for watching also stay tuned we got two
more shows we got Danny playing goat
simulator oh yeah and uh the podcast
podcast 3 where Kody will be the star
yeah definitely i right happy Friday
everyone take care